the movie is set in the near future
after the end of a Great War called the
ruin civilization collapsed and over 90
percent of the population perished some
people in North America built a
community one of true equality whose
building blocks are a set of rules all
the children born in the community learn
rules like using precise language only
wearing clothes assigned to them taking
morning injections obeying the curfew
always telling the truth Etc no one in
the community has a last name and all of
their memories have been wiped out in
their world differences are not allowed
and there is no Fame no losers and no
winners the elders eliminated all of
that so that there would be no conflict
between anyone color fear pain envy and
hate are alien to them in the past
history of mankind has been concealed
forever it is a world without PewDiePie
the movie follows the story of a young
teenager named Jonas and his best
friends Asher and Fiona as they are
ushered into adulthood adulthood is a
big deal especially for this community
because it is when children are assigned
a job job that they will have to carry
out for the rest of their lives Asher
and Fiona are excited about the
graduation but Jonas is nervous as he
still doesn't know his purpose and feels
lost Jonas has always felt different
from other children he sees things
differently than others Asher is the
Joker of the group while Fiona is
someone who makes everyone smile it is
the day before the graduation ceremony
and the three friends are at the
nurturing Center for their volunteer
work because things like love and
relationships are forbidden in this
community all humans are genetically
engineered newly born babies are kept in
the center intended to by a team of
medical staff and volunteers they are
then assigned to a family where they
will continue living until they become
adults Fiona loves working with children
and she wishes the elders would give her
some job at the nurturing Center Jonas's
Father David who works at the center
asks Fiona to calm a crying baby if she
really has what it takes to become a
nurse to his surprise she effortly does
this with a Simple Touch of her hand
David then reveals that the baby's name
is Gabe and that he is just three months
old after finishing their shift the Trio
returns to their homes before the curfew
in the next scene Jonas is having dinner
with his family where he suddenly asks
his parents if they were nervous before
they were assigned to their current
positions however David assures him that
the elders have been watching him
closely since he was a baby so they know
where to put him Jonas's mother Linda
then reveals that a local teacher has
been to a rehabilitation Camp of some
sorts when David asks if there was any
other choice she mentions that the other
choice was a place called elsewhere the
next day at the annual ceremony of
advancement the Chief Elder of the
community addresses the audience
virtually through a hologram after a
while the ceremony begins with the
release of the elderly citizens who have
spent all their lives working for the
community now they will be sent to
elsewhere where they will retire it is
followed by the assigning of the new
children engineered by the community's
geneticists finally the Chief Elder
assigns the adult kids to their
positions during the ceremony Jonas
notices an old man looking over at him
one by one each kid gets their job Asher
is given the job of a drone pilot while
is assigned to be in the nurturing
Center something she was dreaming of
Jonas eagerly waits for his turn but he
is skipped over and all the other kids
are announced in the end Chief Elder
finally calls out his name and reveals
that he hasn't been assigned a job
because he has been selected for
something bigger she states that Jonas
has all four attributes intelligence
Integrity courage and an ability to look
Beyond all of which convinced the elders
to select him as the new receiver of
memories she tells a puzzle Jonas that
his training involves a lot of pain that
he can't even fathom at last Jonas is
given a triangular drive and everybody
starts chanting his name the next day
Jonas heads for his training at a small
house on the edge of the community Cliff
overlooking a vast Skyline from now on
he is exempt from all rules governing
rudeness that means he can ask questions
to people lie to them and even crack
jokes however aside from his daily
medicine he can't receive other
medicines especially painkillers he also
can't discuss his training with anyone
not even his family as Jonas slowly
enters the house he comes across a large
Library where he meets the old man from
the ceremony the man is the giver who
will pass on memories of the past to the
receiver these memories are the secret
history of the world dating Generations
back no one else in the community has a
history of the past and when the elders
require any guidance on matters that are
beyond their experience The Giver
provides a wisdom wasting no time the
man grabs both of Jonas's wrists and
sends him into a memory of snowy Woods
there Jonas rides a sled down a snowy
hill something which he has never
experienced or even heard of soon he
comes across a mysterious looking cabin
and the next second Jonas snaps out of
his memory amazed he asks the giver why
they don't have sleds or snow in their
community and the latter responds that
it was a very distant memory and there's
no snow anymore because of climate
control he continues that sleds require
snow and snow requires cold which
destroys crops and makes transportation
of food difficult Jonas asks to see more
but the man takes him outside for some
fresh air during the walk Jonas inquires
about the person who has chosen to be
the receiver before him but the giver
responds with silence that night baby
Gabe is brought to Jonas's home by a
nurse from the nurturing Center still
crying the family has been assigned to
watch over him until he catches up
meanwhile Jonas notices a mark on Gabe's
wrist the same Mark that he and The
Giver have on exact same spot this makes
him realize that Gabe will also be
selected as the receiver of memories
someday as the days pass Jonas continues
to train under the giver and stops
taking his daily injections because of
this he experiences pain for the first
time when he is bitten by a bee in his
memory he also starts seeing colors
around him later Jonas meets up with his
friends for a brief reunion Asher talks
about how he's been able to fly the
drones close to elsewhere he describes
it as an isolated place with two rocks
touching at the top forming a triangle
after a while Asher heads to work and
the other two start having fun they
slide down a slope and scream out loud
disturbing everyone in the area at the
bottom of the slope Jonas goes over to
help Fiona up but a voice through the PA
system announces that they cannot touch
people outside their family unit I know
what you're thinking Jonas but you can't
receive that meanwhile The Giver meets
with the Chief Elder over his training
with Jonas she warns him to take it easy
with the boy reminding him to not repeat
the mistake he made with the last
receiver who apparently committed the
unthinkable in the next session Jonas
finds a map on the library floor in it
he notices his home and the Triangular
rock that Asher told him about the cliff
is marked as a boundary of the memory
Jonas wonders if the memories will be
released if a receiver crosses the
boundary as he continues inquiring about
it the giver changes the topic and shows
Jonas a piano which amazes him Giver
reveals that the daily injections take
away emotions of the community members
and make them dull saying this he holds
Jonas's hand and takes him to a party
place where people are dancing and
having a great time there Jonas also
sees himself kissing Fiona passionately
over the course of the next few days
Jonas experiences all the Wonders and
calamities of the ancient world he
learns about different religions
cultures and even Witnesses a child
being born The Giver warns him about the
tremendous cruelty of the past but Jonas
insists on seeing more His Wish is
eventually granted but little did he
know about the horrors he is going to
witness when Jonas Sees an elephant
being brutally shot down he breaks into
tears that night at home Jonas notices
Fiona combing her hair through his
window and feels a weird sensation he
thinks about it for a while and finally
realizes that he is in love later he
asks his parents if they love him but
Linda tells him to use precise language
she mentions that the word is Antiquated
and that it no longer has any
application however Jonas becomes
obsessed with the word and tells baby
Gabe that he loves him causing the
latter to smile the next day Jonas finds
The Giver collapsed on the floor worried
he rushes to his side and grabs his hand
just then Jonas Witnesses a memory where
he finds himself in the position of a
soldier his partner has been gunned down
and there are dead bodies everywhere
terrified by what he just saw Jonas
storms out of the house immediately
despite the giver's attempts to stop him
in a flashback sequence it is revealed
that the previous receiver a teenage
girl named Rosemary was also distraught
by the images that she saw later Jonas
meets Fiona and angrily tells her that
he is quitting his job this of course
doesn't sit well with Fiona so she
reminds him of the punishment for
quitting which is being sent away to
elsewhere however Jonas could care less
and he instead advises her to stop
taking her morning injections that numb
the emotions he also asks her to meet in
the Triangle the next day Fiona agrees
but only under the condition that he
will return to his job in the next scene
Jonas returns to his training house
where he sees a memory of The Giver
playing the piano alongside Rosemary as
he watches in shock the real Giver
explains that after witnessing death
Rosemary became so horrified that she
asked to be released from her Duty
hearing this Jonas assumes that she is
still alive and elsewhere but the giver
tells him that elsewhere is death he
then shows Jonas a video projection of
his father in the nurturing center with
a baby that is deemed too weak in the
video David injects something into the
baby's head killing it instantly the
strange thing is that he doesn't even
know what he is doing David is simply
carrying out his work that he was
assigned to Jonas is taken aback by the
Revelation and he argues that people
should be given their memory so that
they know what they're doing however the
giver tells him that he can't do
anything about it the next morning Jonas
meets Fiona and gets to know that she
took his advice and skipped her
injections so without wasting any time
he takes her to a secluded spot and
kisses her For the First Time Fiona is
Amazed by the sensation and Jonas tells
her that there's a lot more that she
hasn't seen oh afterwards he returns
home and learns that baby Gabe is set to
be released the next day because he has
failed his maturity test alarmed Jonas
sneaks out at night to save his little
brother he rushes to the giver's house
and asks for help and the latter says
that there is only one way Jonas will
have to cross the boundary of the edge
and release all the memories this will
turn the zombie-like beings into humans
once again meanwhile Chief Elder finds
out about Jonas's plans and immediately
contacts The Giver via a hologram am she
wants to know his exact location but the
giver lies to her and sends her away he
then shows Jonas a ray of memories to
make him stronger and hands him the map
before sending him off after a while
Jonas makes it to the nurturing Center
where he meets Fiona he anxiously
explains the entire predicament to her
and surprisingly she agrees to help the
two then search for baby Gabe around the
facility and once they find him Fiona
kisses Jonas one last time she then
creates a distraction for the incoming
guards allowing Jonas enough time to
escape with the baby on a motorcycle he
is still being watched by the elders
though but once he makes it outside the
community they will lose track of him as
a last resort the Chief Elder orders
Asher to use his drone and finish off
The Runaway boys the latter is a bit
hesitant but he agrees to do it for the
sake of his people soon he flies his
drone outside the community and
eventually locates Jonas running across
the desert without any remorse Asher
pulls his former best friend with a beam
and it appears as if he is going to
execute him however to everyone's
surprise he simply drops Jonas into a
river allowing him to flee elsewhere the
elders watch video footage of Fiona
kissing and helping Jonas thus she is
apprehended and brought into a chamber
where Jonas's father is ready to release
her into elsewhere The Giver Chief Elder
and everyone else also arrived to
witness the event The Giver is against
the brutality and he tries to change the
Elder's decision by revealing that
Rosemary was actually his own daughter
he loved her cared for her and wanted
her to stay but despite his will she was
sent to elsewhere from which she never
returned the speech is a moving one
however that she Felder is not phased at
all so she orders David to inject Fiona
immediately on the other hand Jonas has
reached a snowy place just like what he
saw in his memories he also finds the
sled with the help of which he and Gabe
finally cross the borders of the
imaginary world this triggers a massive
reaction causing all the memories and
colors to return to the community
everybody begins to feel again and Fiona
is saved from her impending demise in
the nick of time in the final scene we
see a near Frozen Jonas still carrying
Gabe and walking through the bitterly
cold snowy woods soon he finds the cabin
from earlier in the movie he thinks he
hears people inside singing though it
could merely be an echo whatever happens
Jonas acknowledges that The Giver has
given him and his brother A New Hope the
movie ends as Jonas and the infant Gabe
enter the cabin
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching